the gyro can experience pinja listen I
just love the rant and if you want to
listen to Penn Jillette's Sunday schools
it's [ __ ] amazing
IIIi want to meet him so bad we didn't
figure this out ten years ago but come
on that's a great it's a great Rancho
give me the talk to you welcome me about
what it's a business what the [ __ ] do
you want nobody knows prison is a
business and that's what it is it's a
[ __ ] business guys it's important
when a guy like Penn Jillette's great
you do for you break the [ __ ] law you
go to jail you sell weed against the law
and can bail you get caught you go to
jail I went to jail I'm responsible I
learned how to [ __ ] it that's it what
are you gonna do there's a law you
cannot [ __ ] do it you're gonna go to
jail jail and prison are a [ __ ]
business they're a business that's why
you get a ticket driving with the phone
how much they tell you it is how much
they tell you this twenty five hours
until you go down to LA County and it's
two hundred and twenty five hours cuz
you got to pay the court costs the
prison fee the judges vacation it's a
it's a [ __ ] business guys they're
gonna raise the taxes now for [ __ ]
parking tickets it's a business the [ __ ]
you want me to do this is the oldest
conversation the book they shoulda
legalized this after they shot Kelly
they didn't we're [ __ ] fortunate that
we live in California and we don't have
to abide by this when was the last time
you when a storm they kicked the door
down Joe Rogan how about you my friend
so all this [ __ ] you guys talk about
them kicking the doors the feds I've
never seen it I go get weed everyday'
stop scaring these [ __ ] white kids
and getting them talking this is
nonsense this is nonsense twelve they
should killed it was yeah well I never
drank it so what so who gives a [ __ ] it
applies for everything dog there's a lot
of people were in jail I get out every
day on a DNA or whatever you break the
law you sell five pounds a week you
gotta go to jail it's a business you
didn't do nothin wrong but it's a
business they have guidelines if you get
caught with 30 28 grams of blow you have
to do a certain amount of [ __ ] time
you get caught with a quarter on so we
have to do a certain amount of time you
got caught with it why are you crying on
me for you got caught word I was a
criminal for 30 years every somebody
gets caught with blow what we
no you follow me there's a way to do it
there's a way laughs how the [ __ ] you
gonna get caught with [ __ ] weed and
not think you're gonna go to jail if you
live in [ __ ] Ohio and if [ __ ] can
talk to you ever you're gonna go to jail
I kind of see your point but I also see
his cuz it's a it's an important mind
it's brilliant oh yeah that's important
you know I time together with Fallon and
the presents hit but I don't I'm smoking
look look here this is what I think
about your whole drug thing that's like
the same thing I've rubbed my balls with
for the last 32 years with the sativa
isn't the [ __ ] just get high dog you
be black what's drama to the gift that
God gave us again huh you got too much
drama I can't I gotta put a dig at the
end of the joint to be cool meanwhile
you're smoking on the [ __ ] electronic
cigarette smoking the electron well I'm
smoking think about that I'm smoking
that's all that matters at the end of
the week that's all that matters
welcome people want to be intelligent
all the time I can't wait you ever stage
tonight no [ __ ] is due period rare for
people and give it three out of four
people in there for rape and murder what
are you telling me Joey meatballs calm
down who gives a [ __ ]
show people that you give a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] I give a [ __ ] I don't want
people locked up in jail for weed you
know it's my favorite thing Joe they
came in here jack boot thugs Milan
[ __ ] haul you away for your little
kamikaze pencil comedian for 20 years I
drink from time to time don't ever get
behind of a car when I'm drunk another
DUI that's a choice you make these are
all the choices you make bro so what are
we getting at I know it's illegal I know
it should be illegal and I know that
John Lennon's gonna make a comeback
but for today mm but today but for today
if you get caught smoking [ __ ] in New
York you're goin to jail
I don't care what you said bro I love
hearing your talk I never [ __ ] I'm gonna
pull up with this nonsense I was going
off yesterday I was saying how Joey Diaz
will get mad about ketchup about
this [ __ ] Heinz ketchup we're ranch
have you every time my ranch
[ __ ] hate red [ __ ] people eat that
[ __ ] I don't know how people could eat
ranch I like when I go to a place and I
say you oh you have wings and they say
it comes with ranch I get up and leave
even if I don't get the wings because if
you're gonna serve wings or ranch I
don't wanna do business with you how do
I do business with you
I'm very easy I'm very [ __ ] easy so
if you [ __ ] up pork fried rice what do
we have to talk about wings must be done
with boochi boochi
yeah like the way they invented in
Buffalo New York original you're gonna
show up with that ranch that smells like
somebody's ass it was the same rate
ranch is starting to replace ketchup
yeah that's good if you're a [ __ ]
hillbilly and you want to taste the ass
and your mom [ __ ] I hate that [ __ ]
red [ __ ] go put it close to me don't put
it around me and see the blue cheese
with wings I go [ __ ] your mother that's
the next shirt all right please you're
gonna give me a [ __ ] low I'll ranch
with [ __ ] wing I can say go [ __ ] your
mother in there this [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna
give me branch with my honey why people
around part of the ranch like don't
order that [ __ ] around me do me that
favor right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Freaks and Geeks lovers and children
what's going on ladies and gentlemen